- STUPID WOODY
TRYING TO CHANGE ME.
I DON'T NEED BEAR BEANS
TO BE MALLOY.
WOODY, YOU KNOW
HOW FAT YOU ARE?
UH...ABOUT...AVERAGE
FOR AN AMERICAN MAN YOUR AGE.
ETHEL, YOU LOOK LOVELY.
WHAT THE HELL AM I SAYING?
CONNIE,
THE DYKE STORE CALLED,
AND THEY'VE APOLOGIZED
FOR THEIR VERY OFFENSIVE NAME.
- GROW!
GROW, DAMN YOU, GROW!
OR DO YOU WANT THIS
TO HAPPEN TO YOU?
THEY DON'T EVEN RESPOND
TO THREATS.
- WE DEAD.
I KNEW IT.
- WAIT A MINUTE.
I REMEMBER SOMETHING.
- HIS TESTICLES ARE PRODUCING
LARGE AMOUNTS OF TESTOSTERONE.
HE'LL BE FULL-GROWN
PRACTICALLY OVERNIGHT.
OVERNIGHT. OVERNIGHT.
- THAT'S IT!
♪
[squishing]
- STEVE, HAVE YOU LOST
YOUR GODDAMN MIND?
THIS IS YOUR PLAN?
BEAR BALL JUICE?
- IT'S TESTOSTERONE.
DIDN'T YOU SEE
MY THOUGHT BUBBLE?
- MAN, I'M GETTING
OUTTA HERE.
WHITE PEOPLE DO
SOME [bleep]ED UP SHIT.